and finally new or old Democrats must
stop talking about playing as dirty as
the Republicans and actually start doing
it ever ever since Democrats lost the
2016 election there's been a backlash to
the when they go low we go high approach
every when they go low we got to do
whatever we have to do when they go low
we go high I think the Democrats have to
go a little lower now they go low we
kick yeah it's a nice applause line but
they never say what exactly it is we
should do just we gotta fight dirty okay
but how typical Democrats bringing a
notion to a gun fight Republicans always
have dirty tricksters on their payroll
like Igor and Lev Roger stone Lee
Atwater Karl Rove Giuliani well we're
gonna need some reptilian scumbags of
our own good Democrats who are willing
to stand up and do the wrong thing
and I know just the guy you used to love
him Michael avenatti come on down
Michael in the brief time we've come to
know you it turns out that you are a
dirty filthy immoral unscrupulous
cheating lying stealing lowlife lawyer
[ __ ] and your party needs you
but he's in prison so let me get the
ball rolling
first off let's target Trump's brain
that's an old dirty trick of theirs in
2014 Karl Rove suggested Hillary might
have suffered a traumatic head injury
from a fall and she had to go on ABC
News and assured Diane Sawyer that her
brain still worked she's been dying in
the conservative run tabloids for years
she stumbled once getting into a car and
Fox News started running her obituary
[Music]
of course hillary was and is fine
meanwhile Trump is a neurological mess
but the Democrats are too scared to make
an issue of it when actually it would
cut together really well as a campaign
ad and let me begin by wishing you a
beautiful like look there's one cool
people who's named Donald Trump for a
long time all say he's not the same
person he was and then they announced
there was nobody's now Democrats decided
to shield at shelter critical look look
worried but I had is that maybe he's
having small strokes sometimes he simply
can't speak really in armors what must
be going on in his mind
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the
investigation the oranges how it started
no one wishes ill hell from the
president but a country needs a leader
to be there
god bless the United States Navy
[Applause]
as Melania often says to Donald that
wasn't so hard make that go viral what
Jeb because the Democrats should really
be running that for real next thing we
have to do is give Trump a taste of his
own medicine at the second debate with
Hillary in 2016 he went there and put
three of Bill Clinton's sex accusers in
the audience
Trump has 25 accusers they could fill
the entire gallery at the debates all
with matching [ __ ] hats
and stormy Daniels who famously said
Trump's penis was short with a giant
head a mushroom dick if you will well
why can't she be sitting right in front
picking mushrooms off of a pizza Donald
Trump is not a hard man to drive crazy
the State of the Union coming up on
Tuesday supposed to be his big victory
lap okay so you know he's gonna go full
crackhead and started gloating and lying
his ass off that would be a good time to
remember Republicans set this precedent
the reforms I'm proposing would not
apply to those who are here illegally
they can say you lied Obama we can't
yell you lie as the guy who lies like
raccoons eat trash
not only should the Democrats in the
hall shouted out everybody at home
should too let's practice it now I'll be
Trump at the State of the Union the
Democrats tried to impeach me over a
perfect I was the person who saved
pre-existing condition I only watch
real-time accidentally this 2020
election is destined to be the dirtiest
rat [ __ ] astir especially when
Republicans start using footage like
this President Trump is a total and
complete [ __ ]
okay that would be damning but of course
he never said it that's what's called a
deep fake Obama's face and voice
manipulated digitally to make it look
like he's speaking words that in reality
never came out of his mouth it's the
future of sleazy American political
advertising so let's get in on it now
and I know I know just what our first
deep fake video should be the P tape the
infamous recording of Trump being
entertained by two urinating hookers in
Moscow well we found it would you like
to say
[Applause]
[Music]
you're welcome as always feel free to
repost like and subscribe
you